like we've done in the last several
videos let's assume that we have some
set of basis vectors b and let's say so
our basis is going to be v1
v2
all the way to vk
so this will span a subspace of
dimension k and let's assume that each
of these guys each of these guys are
members of rn so v1
v2 all the way to vk
they're all members of rn
now in the last video we saw that we can
define a change of basis matrix and it's
a fancy word but all it means is a
matrix that has these basis vectors as
its columns so v1
v2
all the way to
vk as its columns
so we're going to have k columns we're
going to have k columns and we're going
to have n rows because each of these
guys are members of rn so they're going
to have n entries so we're going to have
n rows so it's going to be an n by k
matrix and we saw in the last video that
if i have some matrix a if we have sorry
if i have some vector a
that is a member of rn
then and assuming that a is in the span
of b i can represent a i could say that
a is equal to
is equal to the change of basis matrix
times
the coordinates of a with respect to our
bases this is what we saw in the last
video if i have the coordinates of a
with respect to b
i can multiply it by the change of basis
matrix and i'll get my vector a in
standard coordinates or if i have my
vector n standard coordinates then i can
solve for my vector a in coordinates
with respect to b we saw that in the
last video now let's take the special
case
let's take the special case let's assume
that let's
assume let's assume that c is invertible
let's assume that c
is
invertible
what does that mean or what does that
tell us about c well if c is invertible
it's two things it means that c
is a square matrix or it has the same
number of rows and columns and that it's
rows or columns you can pick either of
them have to be linearly independent so
linearly independent let's just pick
columns
now the second statement is a bit
redundant we know that c has linearly
independent columns because its columns
are bases for a subspace so basis by
definition all of the vectors have to be
linearly independent so we know this is
you know this is a bit
redundant redundant but what's
interesting is if we know that c is
invertible c has to be square and if all
of these vectors are members of rn then
k has to be equal to
then k has to be equal to n so c is
square means that k is equal to n or
that we have or that we have
n
basis vectors
and
now if that's the case what is the span
of b
think about it we have k
sorry we have n linearly independent
vectors
n
linearly
independent vectors
in rn
in rn so anytime you have n linearly
independent vectors in rn those guys are
a basis for rn because any basis that
has n entries and they're all linearly
independent is going to be a basis for
rn
so then b
b is
a basis
for
rn so if we know that c is invertible we
also know that you can get to any vector
in rn by some linear combination of your
of your basis vectors right there so we
don't you know in the last video we had
to make sure that this guy
that this guy was in the span of these
vectors but now we don't have to make
sure because if c is invertible
if c is invertible
invertible
then
then the span
of b
is going to be equal to
rn or another way you could say it is if
the span of b is equal to rn if we have
n vectors here if k was equal to n then
we know that the span of b would be
equal to rn and so we'd have n vectors
here and linearly independent columns
here and would be an n by n matrix with
all of the columns linearly independent
so then c would be invertible so we
could write if and only if so we could
write it the other way
if the span
of b
is rn
then
c is invertible
and that's useful because if either of
these things are true then we can
rewrite the same equation so let's say
if we know if we know this and we're
looking for that we can just multiply c
times that let's say we know this and
we're looking for that before we had to
do that augmented matrix and solve for
it what not but if we know c is
invertible
if we know c is invertible then one we
know that any vector here can be
represented but it's in the span of our
basis so any vector here can be
represented as linear combinations of
these guys so you know that this is that
any vector can be represented in these
coordinates or with coordinates with
respect to our basis and so we can just
take we can multiply both sides of the
equation times c inverse and what do you
get if you multiply so it becomes c
inverse c times our coordinates of a
with respect to b is equal to c inverse
times a this is just the identity
matrix right there so we just get
another way of writing this is that the
coordinates of a
with respect to our basis b which spans
all of our n
is equal to c inverse
times
our vector a let's apply this a little
bit let's apply this
let's
use this information what we've done in
this video let's do some concrete
examples
so let's say i have
some basis
let's say my basis is equal to let me
define two vectors i'll do it this way
so let's say i have v 1
is equal to
the vector
1 3
and let's say v 2
is equal to
the vector
2 1
and i have a basis
that is equal to the set of
v1
and v2
now i'll leave it for you to verify that
these guys are linearly independent but
if i have two linearly independent
vectors in r2
then
v
is
a basis
for
r
two
and if we draw if we make the change if
we write the change of basis matrix if
we say c is equal to
1 3 2 1 we know that c is invertible and
actually to show that c is invertible we
can actually just calculate its inverse
so what's the determinant of c
the determinant of c
is equal to one times one
one times one minus two times three so
it's equal minus five that's the
determinant of c and so c inverse we
figured out a general formula for doing
this for two by two matrices is equal to
one over the determinant of c so one
over five or one over minus five
times
you switch these two guys so you switch
the ones and you make these two guys
negative so minus two
and then minus three and the very fact
that this guy was the determinant of c
was non-zero told us that this was
invertible but anyway this is c inverse
so let's say that i have some vector
let's say that i have some vector a
that is a member of r
2 let's say that a i'm just going to
pick some random numbers a is equal to
7 2. and i want to find out what the
coordinates of a are with respect to my
basis b
with my respect with respect to the
well we go to this situation we know
what
we know what a is
so we just multiply a times c inverse to
get this guy right here to get the
coordinates of a with respect to b
so let me write that down so what is c
so c is that c inverse is that so we
could write
the coordinates of a
with respect to b is equal to c inverse
times the standard coordinates of a
or this is the same thing let me put the
actual numbers here the coordinates of a
with respect to b are going to be equal
to c inverse
which is minus one-fifth
times one minus three minus two 1
times
times a
times a times
2 and what is this equal to this is
equal to minus
1 5
and then we're going to get
1 times 7 plus 2 minus 2 times 2 so it's
minus 4 so 7 minus 4 is 3
and then we're going to get minus 3
times 7 which is minus 21 plus 1 times 2
so minus 21 plus 2
is
minus 19.
so the coordinates of a with respect to
the basis b so the coordinates of a with
respect to b are going to be equal to
let me just multiply the negative fifth
you get minus
three fifths and then you get plus 19
fifths so 19
over
five
just like that and let's verify that
let's take
this means that a is equal to minus
three fifths times our first basis
vectors plus 19 fifths times our second
basis vector let's verify that that's
the case so let's see minus three fifths
times
our 1 3
plus
19 fifths
times
2 1 let's see what this is going to be
equal to
this is equal to
this is equal to let me write the two
vectors this is minus three fifths minus
three fifths
this is minus three fifths times three
is minus nine fifths minus nine fifths
and then we're going to add it to this
guy
so this guy is 2 times 19 is 38 fifths
fifths
right and then 19 fifths times 1 is 19
and then if you add
these two vectors together what do we
get we get
minus three-fifths plus thirty-eight
fifths that's thirty-five fifths
thirty-five fifths is seven
minus nine-fifths minus nine-fifths plus
nineteen fifths that's ten fifths or two
and there you have it that was our
original a so we see that a can
definitely be represented as minus
three-fifths times our first basis
vector plus nineteen-fifths times our
second basis vector now that was the
case where we had some vector a and we
wanted to represent it in coordinates
with respect to b what if we had the
other way
what if we said that some vector let's
say some vector w's
coordinates with respect to b
are i'll do something simple r
1 1
r 1 1 then what is w in standard
coordinates
well there we can just multiply
we can just multiply the change of
remember w
is just equal to the change of basis
matrix times w's coordinates with
respect to the basis b so w
is going to be equal to the change of
basis matrix
which is just one three two one
it's one three two one
times
the coordinates of w with respect to b
one one
which is equal to
1 times 1 plus 2 times 1 is 3 and then 3
times 1
3 times 1 plus 1 plus 1 so 3 times 1 is
3 plus 1 is 4.
so w is just equal to the vector 3 4. so
there you see if our change of basis
matrix is invertible which is really
just another way of saying that our
basis spans rn in this example it was r2
then you can easily go back and forth
between coordinate representations in
our standard coordinates in our standard
coordinates and coordinate
representations and coordinate
representations in uh with respect to
our basis
right this is with respect to the basis
this is in standard coordinates this was
with respect to the basis this is in
standard coordinates and you can do that
just simply by either using this
information or
just saying oh the coordinates with
respect to the base is equal to c
inverse times a are the inverse of our
change of basis matrix times a or saying
our coordinates in standard
with respect to the standard basis is
just equal to the change of basis matrix
times the coordinates with respect to
the basis